and also orlando that's not your only  your creation because uh congratulations  becoming a new dad  yay daisy  in august oh look at the tiny hand  because we saw katie's bump when she was  she was on the  she was on the lockdown show back in may  and is it true that you used to sing to  the bump  yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was  saying  you know i've got this buddhist practice  so i'm constantly talking to her  chanting singing to her now i sing  sing anything that has daddy in it i'm  like just because i wanted to say dad  before she says anything else  i'm like dad he loves his daddy does the  baby go  like can you put katy perry on yeah  that was really bad he's like yeah mom's  going to be much better  than you alexa play mommy  [Laughter]  you haven't lost the game yet she hasn't  spoken yet then actually she sort of has  said a bit of  that every time i come up she's like  she's very excited to see me and  yeah yeah get katy perry in here  you